hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to lullaby for an electric
toaster I was drawn to this game because
it reminded me of Brave Little Toaster
but apparently it's a survival horror
game I don't know how or why but I'm
really at oh hey whoa where all they got
me on the music now I'm afraid of the
dark the floors are faster stay up I
love the floors are bananas what's going
down on the floors well I don't think I
want to know what's going on the floors
oh man is this like the antithesis to I
am bread whoa whoa
kill them with fire who is that hi Oh
the floors are bananas okay the floors
are literally bananas okay oh god oh god
oh god oh jeez Wow
alright whoa there what the hell that's
awesome and creepy what do we do oh
that's so cool level 2 sinker burn I
don't know what that means
oh I imagine that if me a toaster goes
into our sink Oh piss piss piss bubi
bubi bubi huh oh that doesn't look good
good okay jumped over it woah I'm doing
amazingly good for being a Brave Little
Toaster
Oh God I need to re-watch Brave Little
Toaster after this ah crap is it on
Netflix or some other laughs what it
hurts
please where am I go oh god where am I
Oh piss boobie boobie put me in with
these mmm
Oh God can I get some bearings now which
one of these vegetables and our fruits
are evil Jesus oh my god that was
literally panic-inducing
law
this I love this hey whoa you freaking
weird no bad touch bad touch bad touch
Oh bad bad faucet damn it ha oh I don't
want to go to the bananas floors oh boo
boo me okay
why is this like this who did this whoa
fridge to Noir
what in the world this is far beyond The
Brave Little Toaster level of
comprehension okay something has gone
awry I mean I'm pretty sure I have a
good grasp on what reality is but no
cluvin fun don't feel right about none
of this hmm okay
whoo yes I definitely want to go that
way but it seems a bit dangerous god
it's like I'm moving a grid I'm not
entirely like Oh God
so Oh God okay Wow jeez get out your
bread are you bread go away
I ain't toasting nothing today I ain't
have nothing to do with bread well
what's over there can I get over there
is there something over there why is
that red why is that red what I say
roasted onions are a key ingredient to
what nightmares a mystery door wait what
was the green pointing to then I don't
know which one I should have followed
well there's the door I'm curious so huh
okay I'm not as curious okay I need to
find three keys keys
Cree's ah you're scary
Jesus okay I mean this is surprising it
well made for a lamentation of a toaster
game ooh boy
oh oh oh my first death damn it
okay they said roasted onions or a keep
well here's my second death two-for-one
combo on the market Blair's an idiot
train okay
so god damn it stop you've only just
begun light be come to die oh good you
gave me more life ah I'm not bad swear
I'm good oh shut up with your
patronizing roar God okay it is very
difficult because it's it's not like the
controls are direct the controls are
actually a little wobbly okay
don't trust the green arrows nowhere
jump what are these I want to jump he's
the ghost of my toaster friends ooh boy
okay we'll go that way that fat fat fat
fat oh come on
ha gullible fool
Danah where am I gonna find key roasted
onions ah I know what I need to do I
need to roast these onions the roasted
onions are key Oh God ahahahaha how do i
roast him what a way roast them on is
there a fire anywhere here I don't see
an oven near there okay so I got a roast
him somehow where do I go for that
can I can I like lead them back towards
the ovens over there ooh hi Wow
that a little hurt okay come this way
you oh you don't want to mess with me
alright so how do i roast
oh I didn't know what you do that oh I
didn't know I had a combat mechanic
that's hilarious
okay one key down this stay away
I'm totally choosing this encounter man
got another one all right big boy come
on come on baby
it does kind of keeping the experience
because I was honestly oh he's dead
already
I have three keys okay damn I was
terrified for no reason I didn't know
that I could fight him all my skill whoa
aah whoa the wait whoa what is that what
what I'm
oh wait
slatton oh my god what the end for now
why huh ah my life has been changed
everything I've ever known and loved is
gone into turmoil now how am I gonna be
able to return to my normal life I
didn't even know there was a let's cook
Jam maybe I should start that for my
next channel a let's cooking channel way
to think through those those are divas
alright I guess that's it
thank you everybody so much for watching
go out and rewatch Brave Little Toaster
again because I know I'm going to
I really hope you're doing this it was
surreal and bizarre but it was so cool
because in the beginning I was actually
scared and then won the world either way
thank you everybody so much for watching
check out the annotation for more weird
Game Jam games that I played in the past
and as always I will see you in the next
video
you